foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome welcome
uh it's a Friday thank you for joining
me on this Friday usually we do these
things on Saturdays but uh
you know for a couple reasons mainly
just for my own sanity so that I have a
weekend a full weekend we're doing them
on Friday this time
um so thank you all for for joining me
we're talking boss fight 3D challenge
most of you guys know what we're doing
y'all are participating yourselves
um if you don't know what I'm talking
about there's a brand new 3D challenge a
3D Community challenge
um there's links to get started in the
description
go check it out there's a bunch of
prizes
um by Rococo by kit bash3d by kaft and
by Jenga effects they make Emergen
Emergen is free uh for the month while
you guys are working on your boss fight
Rococo also has
um Rococo video which is a free motion
capture no suit needed
um kind of solution to motion capture
right so there's a lot of free stuff
there's also cargo as well from kippash
bunch of assets and whatnot I'm trying
to bring you guys as much value as
possible during this month of August
while you create your art for this
challenge so I'm excited uh what we're
doing on the stream today
basically I'm trying to go
um and do something that I've never done
before I'm trying to
basically I've always done
photorealistic style and I want to do
something colorful and fun and stylistic
and hand-drawn really my goal here was
to
um kind of break out of the monotony of
doing the same thing all the time and
kind of getting burnt out on the same
process and it's like what I love I love
hand drawing stuff it's so much fun for
me and I want to try and bring that to
this process here and make it as fun as
possible for me but that
Mark I don't know like I've never done a
2d process before
um you know so
that's what I'm going to be working on
uh today here let me show you guys where
I'm at so far with my art
um and uh you know we'll hop into it but
uh if you're also working on your boss
fight art this time around
um that's what that's what we're here to
do we're here to work together so we're
just hanging out chilling
um let me show you what I got here
so this um
this scene here is it was inspired by
my time in Japan the trip I took in
Japan uh in
uh when was it in May
this year and we saw we saw Sumo match
and it was crazy it was awesome we were
way up in the background we were like
way up in here we were in the nosebleeds
but it was still super cool and um
you know I'm trying to do some crazy
ridiculous Sumo scene here and have it
be hand drawn and everything have it
look look legit let me get this out of
here clean this up for you guys
so as you can see here this is as far as
I've gotten I hand drew the background
I'm going to walk you through my process
I'm gonna walk you through how I got to
this point and then my goal on the
stream is to build out an animated crowd
for these bleachers uh I want to be able
to draw you know six to ten characters
for the background
populate them
um in Cinema 4D with like different
cloners and whatnot
and be able to animate them and have
control over how they're animated up and
down
um and from there I will save that out
or render that out bring it into After
Effects comp them into this background
which is literally just an image it's
scrolling by in 3D
um and see if we can't get to the point
where there's an animated crowd in the
background and and of course I want to
get to the point where or I want to
build this system out so that if I want
to replace any one of these people or
randomize it in a different way I can
set myself up easily to do that by
either adding more people or changing
the cloner randomizer the seed to just
get me a better look and I want to get
to the point where I can uh
experiment with the the way it feels the
look and the style as opposed to having
to get stuck on the technical side so I
have a pretty good plan in mind and I'm
hoping that we can get this locked in
over the next couple hours
of sun what up son good to see you dude
um heck yeah man thanks for thanks for
popping in it's gonna be sweet what's up
everybody how you doing will I use the
tune Shader you know I don't know I
don't know there's a lot of different
ways to go about this because I do want
a fully animated
um
you know hand-drawn look to the sumo
wrestler that's popping up here to the
guy in the foreground and we have some
characters off to the side as well
and um I don't know exactly how I'm
gonna do that yet
and I'm kind of in the boat here where
like
I need to be able
to be okay with failing
um with it not looking as good as I want
in my head
and I really want to just focus on
having fun with this
um and I want to focus on
experimentation and experimenting with a
new style for me taking the month to
experiment with a new style through this
five seconds of art that's a win for me
so I'm trying not to put too much
pressure on it just trying to have fun
with it and explore so yeah like I said
there's many options I found this
software called um
exit called I wrote it down smack Studio
smack Studio it's crazy it's like this
uh 2D pixel Sprite based art thing where
you can like
you separate the head the arm the
shoulders the hands the Torso the hips
the legs and then you rig it and then it
turns your 2D Sprite into a 3D animated
thing it's super cool
so maybe I'll mess with that when it
gets character but right now we're
focusing on background so let's just
freaking
hop into it let's do it
okay
so here is where I'm at I'm in Photoshop
um and you know what before I even get
here let me start at the beginning guys
let's go to the beginning where is my
taskbar
why is it
here we go okay
boom look at this we're in c4d I'm using
the close project file right we have
close medium and far project files for
you guys this is obviously the close one
um I built out the the ring here and I'm
just blocking out the scene okay
um I got a pure ref board going with a
bunch of different references and stuff
but for now we'll focus on just this
block out so I built this block out you
get
I built this block out using a bunch of
different reference images I'm hitting
NC
and B basically N A through ND are
different shading methods get up here in
c4d by going to the display changing it
here
um
right so
seeing blocking it out and
let's see here
it's pretty self-explanatory I'm just
using a basic like checkerboard material
stretched out so I can kind of give me
the vibe of um it basically gives me
lines here to work with in 3D so that
when I'm tracing this I have some
guidelines but look once I set this up I
was like what the heck
it's not how I want it to look because
yester weekend
last Saturday
uh we we made a drawing together let me
show you
um
we made this together
and it might this might be kind of hard
to tell but yes there's a Sumo jumping
there's character down low and there's a
bunch of smoke and stuff but all this
stuff in the background it's like the
tears of the uh like the different
levels of the stadium
and when I built it out accurately this
is what it's looking like because our
camera is like a 85 or something yeah
it's a long lens
so what I did actually is I grouped all
my stuff together and I used what's
called an ffd if if you go to the Little
Bend these are called modifiers or
something I forget it's like modifiers
or something else determine I should
know all this right
there's a lot I don't know but ffd is in
here where is it ffd boom there it is if
you want to search for it you can hit
shift C type in ffd there it is
um and what you're doing with an ffd
right is
turn that on
and you can see that it's like
stretching out
my block out right
and when I move this around so you can
grab these points
and you can move your block out around
like this and I basically just distorted
it I'm cheating it obviously this is
looking janky but when you go into
camera view it looks exactly how I want
it to look right so this is without the
ffd and this is like a stretched out
version of my block out to give me the
look that I want right
so from here what I did right we have
this in in 3D
or Orbiter orbiting around the boss
so what I want to do from here is figure
out okay how do I hand draw any of this
where do I start and I'm like okay the
the first thing I know how to do is
probably the background because if I'm
looking at this I can see that the
background is like
technically it's the way they did it you
know for animation for you know for all
time which is you have your background
card it's just the 2D painted background
card and it's just being moved
positionally across your scene so in
this case it's just scrolling across the
background I'm like there's not really
much 3D going on there is some and we
can we can cheat that in later and
really accentuate it later later when we
break up our background into different
parts
but for now what I'm doing
here's what I did here's what I did I
since I'm using octane I went into the
camera tag and I changed this camera
type from thin lens to panoramic and
when I do that
it's going to give me a panoramic view
of my of my scene right 360 view of my
scene so in Photoshop what I did was I
used that panoramic view this was the
render that came out right
was was this and originally I tried to
go in and I tried to like Stitch it I'm
like let me grab this this part of the
background and of course we're hiding
these guys and we're hiding the ring
and I'm like let me grab this image let
me grab this image let me grab this
image and just put them next to each
other Photoshop but there is some 3D
Parallax going on and some Distortion so
that didn't work that's why I did the
Panorama got me this and then from there
I'm like okay let me trace this in
Photoshop so I turn the opacity down
boom you get a little
little background going there and here
we go you know
and what I'm doing here to get this look
first off having a tablet really helps
um
doing this with a mouse I I couldn't
even begin to think about how difficult
that would be okay
um
so a tablet really helps with that or if
you have an iPad I know procreate is a
great is a a great way to do this too so
pipoxo
um in the Discord server right
um he I was talking with him yesterday
he's doing a whole 2D animated thing
himself he actually really recommended
recommended procreate if you have an
iPad
um for this kind of stuff it makes it
really easy but you know I'm in
Photoshop here so brush uh B hit B for
brush tool boom
and let's go ahead and make a background
and I just kind of show you guys the
brush I'm working with
if we zoom in here
right it's really nice to have this
because I got pen pressure going
um
and let me just share my brush settings
for you guys basically shape Dynamics
here pen pressure
and then we have a little bit of
scattering here right
give it some texture
um we got again some texture
it's giving us that nice like charcoal
kind of look and then this transfer is
actually helping like smooth out the
edges
um and make it more of like a the harder
I press the thicker it gets
right so that's the idea there
and last lastly here to get this working
I had trouble with it but in the Wacom
settings I know I'm going deep I'm going
deep but hey we're here pen settings
you gotta have Windows ink under mapping
you have to have Windows ink turned on
and I hate Windows ink but you need it
to get this pen pressure stuff working
in Photoshop
so
yeah I basically use that renderer as a
guide to trace this whole thing out
and then from there what I did was back
in c4d is I brought this in
as just a plane and I bent it with a
little Bend modifier
here and of course you can see right you
can wrap this as much as you want
but when you go into camera view right
we wrap it enough so that it you know
reaches the The Edge there boom
and when we orbit around this thing
it's looking pretty darn good
and that's how we got our uh the render
I showed you guys at the beginning of
the stream I'll hold up one more time
and then we're going to get into it okay
check the chat out a little bit while we
do this what's up everybody I saw a
super chat before
um
Mikhail
be kale if I'm saying that right thank
you very much you said uh idea make
sense of five to six different head and
body and hands and randomize combination
of those with color variations
okay yeah lots I love all the different
ways you can go about doing this I I
think it's going to be super sweet
yup you can split it on separate levels
for Parallax it's a good one it's a good
one
yeah hidden Force getting that Wacom
tablet
that's what's up man congratulations
they're really they're really useful
just ask
um where can I find the stream playlist
um what are we using stream beats is
that it sodomontay
yeah so solomona is using
um by the way Mikhail or sodomonte he is
um
I think one of the the first Discord
moderator
um
for the Discord server years ago he's
also the stream producer here so
um yeah he's using stream beats and he
doesn't remember which pack but it's
stream beats for sure
right
[Music]
so Lewis yeah know maybe maybe that's
the way I'll do the background for the
final but I'm just experimenting again
like I said
my only goal here is to experiment with
new Styles and new workflows so I'm
figuring it out as I go
let's get into it guys let's get into it
um
I want to build out this animated
Background by the time this stream ends
let's see if we can do it so I'm gonna
start in Photoshop and I'm gonna build
out my different like people I'm gonna
build out a few different assets so we
have these guys yeah
I just put these together
let's go ahead and break these up into
individual pieces so let's make a new
project here 200 by 200
and I'm gonna bring these guys in just
copy paste this in here
actually that's gonna be massive so give
me a second
boom copy paste that
all right so they're in looking good
and I'm just gonna break these guys up
here
um you know the better way to do this
might be like this actually
I'll do it here where I can actually see
everybody
and we'll go person by person
and we're essentially just creating
the assets
that we're going to use for our animated
crowd
cool
what's up Redux thank you for that Super
Chat very kind of you
thank you thank you
um let's see because if it is
would it be easy to animate all your
cutout art in After Effects or Premiere
and export in a wide format wrap around
boom crowd done that's exactly what I'm
gonna do yes
um I'm going to animate actually in c4d
because I want to populate it easily
with uh with like an array and then I'm
going to composite it in After Effects
because I feel like I'm gonna have the
most control over compositing in After
Effects and I'm going to have the most
control over animation and distribution
in Cinema 4D
um so that's the plan that's the plan
we'll see how that plan works out
throughout the Stream
all right so I'm going to Center all
these guys up
[Music]
I'm really excited for this so reference
wise
um one of my favorite games
over the last few years was a fighting
game called Streets of Rage 4.
and I think Streets of Rage is a game
from like the 80s Maybe
um I never played them but my buddy
Cliff was like dude this Streets of Rage
4 is coming out I played them as a kid
um and my God is that game incredible
the art style is insane
um it's on the switch I love the switch
man
it's my favorite
and uh their art style is super cool let
me pull up
a quick my pure ref board for you guys
[Music]
give you an idea so Streets of Rage
is like we're kind of looking like this
for the art style
right this is very refined
very nice Line work here
good
I love it absolutely wonderful
so this is kind of the windows ink man
never never a friend really Windows Inc
I don't know why you're trying to use
Windows ink because it just screws
everything else up and the backgrounds
look at the backgrounds
dude these backgrounds are beautiful
also
Donald Glover back here
I think that's like an actual little
Easter egg
um
but these backgrounds are beautiful and
that's kind of how I want mine to look
it's a little bit comic Booky a little
bit video gamey
um so it's either that or it's like uh
you know Ghibli watercolor Style
right
but man these are beautiful
absolutely beautiful
okay and then now now to my pile of
garbage here okay um let's see let's get
these
[Music]
worked out here so I'm just gonna
right I want them to be opaque so what
we'll do is
get up in here with a little bit of a
little brush
[Music]
and I'm not too focused on color right
now I'm gonna come back around and
actually do all the color and the style
and all that stuff later I just want to
see if I can get the system set up right
um
so I think the easiest way to do this
[Music]
would probably just to be you know black
on white so let's let's color this
silhouette in for all these guys it
doesn't need to be super clean
but it needs to be
clean enough that I can use it as an
opacity
um map here
so that these guys are see-through
[Music]
and I should definitely be doing this on
the bottom layer
and you know what even faster let me
just do this
nice and quick and dirty
and then control shift backspace is like
we can fill it with white
boom
yep
and then let's go ahead and uh
just so that we have a little bit of
something to work with we can fill this
in with like a
like a gray or something I don't know
just something to give us a little bit
of texture
and go to the next one
[Music]
just want to try and get these out as
quickly as possible
[Music]
and maybe it's like the hair on this one
or something
and the arms
pretty rough but that's okay
come back and refine these later
what's the shortcut for this L okay
okay
foreign
oh my God my tea has been steeping for
freaking the beginning of the stream
it's gonna be dark
epoxo yo
what up apoxo
thanks for the tips yesterday man I
appreciate it
yeah I mean maybe right maybe I don't
even need to refine it I think when I
say refine I mean at least the color
foreign
so what I'm going to do is basically
take these in c4d make a plane 200 by
and duplicate it like crazy let's see
what we can get
animate these guys bobbin up and down
that kind of stuff
almost done here two more for you guys
[Music]
is that it huh I think that's it
foreign
pngs
Photoshop has like the worst saving
shortcut now it's like it's one button
away from closing the entire program
it's so ridiculous like Control Alt
shift W is the shortcut to save now what
the heck
uh
let me gets Windows Inc
Windows 8 dude
get out
no one wants you okay
let's do drawings I guess is this an
asset or is this a drawing
it's an asset I feel like
background
no
crowd let's get specific
crowd let's see BG
crowd one
all right
DJ crowd underscore it's all about
moving fast right I'm just gonna select
that copy it
to
paste it three
four
five
and finally
we have
number six okay so we have our crowd I'm
gonna make a new scene in c4d all right
um the only thing I'm Gonna Keep is the
camera let's do 85.
hop into it cool all right and we're
gonna make um some cards here
so let's grab a plane
and I'm gonna make it 200 by
200.
and maybe we adjust the scale a little
bit later with segments height segments
all one it's just a card right
um since I'm using octane I'm going to
use an octane material
we'll apply it to the plane let's go
ahead and
bring in one of our people
start with this guy
so we these are pngs right
um
so I should be let's see if I drop this
into diffuse
let's just see what it looks like
all right
and let me bring up the live viewer
and render it let's save this out God
dang I'm still in Photoshop shortcuts
uh
crowd system
okay
so we want the background to shine
through right
so let's go back into the material
and I believe that I think the easiest
way to do this is just to pipe it into
the opacity
get stopped
but that's not working
um let's try duplicating it putting it
into the opacity
let's even get rid of the diffuse for a
second
and I want to use the alpha not the
black and white values
so I think typed you would set to Alpha
there you go now it works right so
obviously you guys can see it change
this also
um
let's put the color back on
there you go we got our little guy
um to save vram look at this this is
really tiny it's down here it says use
free in total we have 1.13 gigabytes of
used vram and this might be small enough
to not make a difference but this octane
is reading this as a color image but
it's only black and white if we take the
type to float
1.1 yeah it doesn't change because it's
too insignificant but if you change the
type to float it'll count as a black and
white image which is what it is and
we're going to take up as little vram as
possible with that right so now we have
our card
um
or do what
dude
where did it go
[Music]
just freaking teleported
the heck
dude I'm just gonna blame Windows Inc
ridiculous
ridiculous Alpha
load save
great
locked in let me take a look at you guys
um
oh vold okay that's a nice tip you can
export all the layers as individual
files slash pngs just by clicking on the
four lines on the layers Tab while
keeping all their selected and visible
and click on export
pretty sweet if I select them all
four lines on layers
these guys yeah okay
and then you said
on export
export as
[Music]
oh that's cool man yeah that's helpful
thank you thank you that is very helpful
very very helpful much appreciated
what's up let me go back through here
can you delete or reassign
close project shortcuts yeah I'm sure
you can reassign all that stuff
I'm just used to it I got used to it
you guys are like man he's complaining
but he ain't doing nothing about it
you got me there
you got me there y'all
Logan what am I trying to do all right
for those of you who are just joining me
we'll do a quick recap so basically
here's what's going on
here's what I'm making
um
let's go to VFX renders here we go so
this is what I'm making it's kind of
like a
um hand-drawn style for my boss fight
um 3D art submission right and I'm
trying to experiment with a new style
hand-drawn style and I want to make it
as easy as possible on me the last thing
I want to do is hand draw every frame
everything
30 times no 120 times it's going to be
ridiculous if I do that there's no way
to do that so I have to find cheats and
workarounds to making this 2D style this
hand-drawn style while still hand
drawing a lot of elements I need to
cheat and I need to get uh my final
render in a reasonable amount of time
right so
what I'm doing is I have to fill out
this background so I'm going to fill
these Stadium seats with a bunch of
people and I have a plan on how to do
that we just made our Assets in
Photoshop and now what I'm doing is I'm
going to clone them duplicate them
across EV you know just everything in
Cinema 4D of course you can do it in
blender as well
um but uh we're setting up our crowd
system and then I'm going to bring them
into After Effects composite them into
this image here because you can see
background test it's literally just the
drawing that I made
based off of this blockout
that I modeled
right
so we're working on a crowd system here
okay
[Music]
let's build out the six of these all
right so we need six of these uh we'll
say
crowd one
or rather a person
one
there we go we got our six so I'm going
to make six different ones of these
let's go ahead and name this as
person one
there we go and I'm just going to go
through this
and update these
with all of our assets that we made
really quick here
all right
foreign
drop
super easy super quick
distribute them assets
and I'm using the same image for both
the color and the opacity right so now
we have all six
people
and I'm going to just distribute them
pretty soon we're gonna see some results
amazing amazing amazing amazing
fantastic
fantastic all right so here's we're
gonna do we're gonna take all this right
and we want to duplicate it a whole
bunch
so I'm gonna put them into a cloner
let's make a cloner and we'll put them
all up in this cloner
and look at that we got some people
we got some people
um let us
figure out
how we're gonna do this okay so cloner
grid I think is the way to go
and let me hide the camera for a second
and what I want to do
clone this a whole bunch
out this way I want to stand them up as
well
so we can let's see transformed we're
going to transform like this
yeah we can stand them up like that
and we can clone them a whole bunch
let's try multi-instance
would probably be the fastest
and let's do the end point right so we
set the end point uh
and if I clone this more yeah it'll just
fill in cool
probably bring this in just a little bit
look at this already you're seeing
results back here but we want to get him
on some like bleachers right
so maybe it's a linear actually what I
want is linear
I know there's a way to like stand them
up
foreign
yeah it's like this and then
back like that yeah that's what we want
boom
I feel like can you do this with a grid
though like you should be able to
I don't know Grid's gonna
the best way to do this
foreign
[Music]
amazing right so we're getting there I
just need to get them to to go up
[Music]
in the back and lower in the front I
don't know if grid is the one
we want to set the Clones to random too
um and then let's go ahead and get a uh
let's see
cloner Honeycombs there's less space
between people levels using
plain effector gradient field yeah yeah
I could see that I could see that if we
do
honeycomb
mm-hmm
yeah okay I see what you're saying we'll
get the end point going
let's
open it up a little bit push it back
open it up some more
fill it in
with purple
lots of people
and we'll set the Clones to random yes
that we have
and then I like
see yeah the plane effector
Michael I like it I like it I think it's
possible
let us group this because I don't know
exactly how the plane effector is gonna
work
um we'll go to
the parenthesis let's see let's see
okay so this works I want to move them
up
[Music]
500 but I want the the guys in the front
to go down
so that's going to be Fields linear
field and here we go look at that we're
starting to get it okay
good idea
there it is
but we're going to rotate it
bam look at that look at that
amazing and what we do is we just adjust
the height of it right so 500 we can
take to uh 5 000.
that's a little much
2500 there we go
looking like a stadium
oh
I love it dude I love it when stuff just
works
it works out it works the way you want
it to work
look at that
um shift V shift V that's going to be uh
okay like viewport options you can add
viewport effects and subsurface or not
subsurface
[Music]
um uh what's it called ambient occlusion
that kind of stuff transparency you can
add Shadows make your viewport view look
kind of fancy but I'm using it for safe
frame and I'm just going to turn up the
opacity of that
um we can also lock this
I love it I love it I love it I love it
now what we can do
is we can give it a random effector
right so
let's um select the cloner
and let's go ahead and grab this guy and
let's add a random effector and the
random effector is does exactly what you
think it would do it randomizes
everything we zero it all out and let's
start with a little bit of
maybe that's how you animate them holy
crap dude holy crap
look at this we're gonna do this right
now
this is going down okay
um
Let's uh make a keyframe here
go forward
with G one two three
four five I don't know make another
keyframe six and we'll take that to
I don't know 15 centimeters or something
keyframe one two three four five
that keyframe and then just duplicate
like Loop these keyframes essentially
right so I'll select that those
keyframes there
and I think shift three now shift F3 I'm
sorry select all of these keyframes I
think if we go to
a frame
Shin track after God dang
I know there's a way to like repeat all
this stuff but
I just wish I wish I was better with
this man I wish I knew the program
better
hey because I mean you could just
hold control and duplicate
Bush right
there you go
there's an animated background
that freaking worked holy crap
I like that I like that liked a lot
dang
um like what up that's kind of the
stream though
all right but we want to get to the
point where um we have a render
how about that right so we want to get
to the point where um
let me see here
[Music]
we have them back here I want to get to
the point where I have a render V3 and
they're back they're back there at least
the ones the the centered crowd right
the centered crowd I want to get them
kind of plugged in right
so I think what I'll do
is let's set let's set the stage here
let's go into after effects
[Music]
formula effector for better
randomization I have never messed with
the formula effector and maybe we'll get
there in just a second
all right
all right epoxy says make them a little
curved the they need a bit of depth for
when the camera rotates
well here's the thing apoxo is like I
don't know I think the way I have this
set up
you're not gonna see you're not really
gonna see that
um
but I know I know what you're talking
about let me let me let me we can get
there we'll get there
all right so let's see let's see let's
see make a new project
and I'm going to bring in my background
drawing
right make a new drag it into the new
composition button
and this is
the image I'm using in c4d
right here
to get you know this look that we just
saw in that render V2 right
so in theory
if I can get this animated crowd
exported and in in this layout in After
Effects
pop them in here
as little guys
then uh technically I can export this as
a video
and bring them back
into here
in the background that that's like
that's what I'm trying to do essentially
Christy woodkin you submit early for
feedback and do more than one
um no and no would be the quickest
answer you can only submit one time
um because if I allowed multiple
submissions I would Google Drive would
just be maxed out and I'd have to like
it would take so much longer to pick and
pick the the all renders I have to pick
one from everybody it'd be too much
um and then submitting for feedback
there's just not time to give feedback
to everybody that's what the Discord
channel is for is to use the community
as a way for feedback
um but if you want personal feedback
what we do every single Monday all right
so we'll be doing it this upcoming
Monday at noon Pacific Standard Time
myself and the moderators get together
on the Discord and we have like a voice
chat with everybody and we'll bring up
onto the stage we'll talk out your
render for five minutes and we'll get
through as many people as we can so
that's probably the best way to get um
to get feedback but I would recommend
you using the feedback channel on the
Discord
um and the Discord Community to to get
your feedback at least in the meantime
right
thank you
okay
let us
see all right
um
what's next
all right the formula effector
experiment with the formula effector
I have never used this
holy crap
um
dude there's math up in here come on
dude
what
come on now
we do the wave you say we could do the
wave
that's craziness that's craziness I'm
good on that though I think this is
exactly what I'm going for the random
effector here
very basic very basic
and we can give them a little bit of uh
random rotation as well so let's check
the rotation box
yeah there we go
just a little bit you know 10 degrees a
little some side to side
[Music]
I like it I like it a lot
beautiful
tomek I am glad that you're having a
good time man I know the wave is nuts
though huh
okay
um let's see if we can't get a better
looking uh
aesthetic
here
direct lighting we don't need any path
tracing direct light well path tracing
honestly does brighten it up a little
bit
and I like that because we're getting
light bounces
boom
so now here let's try this let's try
this let's try this
now that we have these guys in place
we can go back to photoshop
and instead of
you know I'll just update one of them
for now
and let's go in let's grab that
custom brush
make it a little bit larger
drop the opacity
and kind of get more of a
[Music]
more of a look here
um and maybe I'll do this for each one
just want to see
I think the quickest way Ctrl L and then
just
max out Max that out yeah
sweet
and then uh because in theory right we
just
save over
the renders from before or the uh the
assets from before and then we're pretty
much good to go
they should auto update and that's the
idea I want to be able to quickly
iterate on these
[Music]
Ctrl L and Photoshop is levels
oh
[Music]
foreign
I just want white that's what
cool all right
so technically I want to duplicate all
that
so that I can
save them Ctrl G Will Group it
and I'll just call this back for backup
and I'm gonna go through and just
essentially merge each one of these so I
can export it all at the same time so
Ctrl e is going to be your merge
and we should have six one two three
four five and six awesome okay
um
I'll select all those we'll go up here
we're gonna hit uh Sport AS pngs yes
export to the crowd
[Music]
awesome awesome okay
so what I'm going to want to do here is
actually rename these
as opposed to having to reintegrate them
[Music]
proud let's see
bring them out here rename them out here
BG underscore
out underscore
copy all that so we can do this quick
one
layer three F2 to rename
foreign
and then replace
now
hopefully they'll all update
there we go but they look weird
it looks squashed
okay
you double click these guys
um
the preview in octane they'll update
there's like a bug with it
that's cool that's fine works out
[Music]
it's uh
I think these are
washed because the actual export is a
different
aspect ratio
for some reason
oh these are all different no I don't
want that
I don't want that
back to photoshop
I'm gonna do that
why do that to me
um let's see export as
canvas size
for all of these
should be 200
by 200.
oh man it's getting me these like
200 by 200
there we go
there we go there we go
export that
alas here we are once more
[Music]
there we go now it's now it's more
normal
cool all right
they're animated up and down amazing all
right so let's see if I zoom out
hmm what is the best way to do this
I want them to flare out
kind of along this line here
so I'm wondering if I could do this with
a plane effector as well if we do uh
scale let's check scale
we want
okay yeah I don't want I don't want that
that's rough
I guess
I guess the hmm
because in a perfect world I just export
them here from after effect or from yeah
from Cinema 4D
and they're kind of along this
setup here
hmm
[Music]
oh
spline okay if I did spline
um let's try something crazy let's go to
the blockout
let's go ahead and grab
this piece here
from a top view
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
copy this spline in here I've never done
this before
[Music]
okay
there we go that's exactly what I want
sweet
all right
oh it's amazing all right so I think
that'll actually line up with
this
um
I need to open it up a little bit more I
think
[Music]
something like that
yeah close enough
all right let's uh go ahead and render
this with a
transparent background
and I guess we just need the the two
frames but since this renders so quick
I'll just render to frame 11.
all right let's let's give this thing a
shot
foreign
[Music]
so who knows you know if there's a
faster way to do this or a better way to
do this but um
I like this I like this I think this can
work
[Music]
curious to see how it goes
all right render's done
let's bring it in After Effects just
double click here
the project window
let's navigate to our tests and we can
click this PNG sequence and it's going
to make a sequence out of this we'll
import it
bring it in
and Alpha is not enabled
back to c4d I want to make sure
and I exported this properly
and we did we got a check Alpha Channel
all right so let's try that again and
before I do that I'm going to make sure
that my cloner is set to random
and we'll render again
[Music]
and right click reload there we go all
right
so we got a crowd here an animated crowd
[Music]
now we need more people
that's for sure
but for this test
[Music]
we'll try that
and I'm just gonna duplicate these guys
a whole bunch
we only need
um
24 frames for 120 frames is our sequence
right
and we want this to be at 24 frames
cool
so now when we duplicate this
a whole bunch
[Music]
there we go
yeah
that's fun
and we can of course change the speed
on all these guys too
and we'll need to brighten them up so
I'm gonna
pre-comp them all put them all into a
folder Ctrl shift C or if you go to
layered you can go down to pre-compose
foreign move them all into a new
composition that's what we want this is
our crowd
and I don't want the background
in there
[Music]
and we'll go ahead and add levels to it
so I'm using what's called um I think
it's called VC console
and it lets you hit control spacebar and
pull up any effect search for any effect
you want this should be built in this is
um from Video Copilot right but we'll do
a levels
and uh just make sure white is actually
White
and also make sure we're in a 16-bit
composition 8-bit is totally fine
that should be good
there we go
wheat
foreign
there you go
there's a little animated background
there I love it I love it I love it
super fun
so now let's see um here's the crazy
thing is that like
I'll essentially have to do this
a couple more times for
these side ones because the side ones
the people are drawn at a different like
perspective right
laughs
but let's fill out the back rows too
all right so
I'm hitting the bracket Key by the way
in After Effects if you hit the bracket
it'll snap the layer to the playhead
like that
and let's get these guys like this
boom
copy them over the heck control D is
duplicate
there we go and the reason why I want to
do this in After Effects is for this
reason
very very specific I'm going to
duplicate my background bring them up
here
and just
do a little bit of this business
right here
and yes I know
I can make this as individual layers in
Photoshop
and maybe we'll get there
but for now
this is the way I'm doing it
boom
foreign
go ahead and mask
that there
mask this there
cool
like duplicate these guys a whole bunch
thank you
I wish there was an easier way you know
that's I feel like I need to get that
tattooed onto my
forehead I wish there was an easier way
[Music]
um
all right bam
[Music]
pre-comp those guys crowd tier two
one
this is technically crowd
tier one
and we'll copy the levels from this guy
okay
I love it I love it I love it
super fun
I'm just gonna keep going with this
right
grab another crowd layer
paste it in I'm using again bracket key
to move this layer instead of dragging
it like this I'm using the bracket key
to snap it to the playhead
and we'll bring these guys up
now technically
[Music]
it's kind of like
um
you know what yeah
we can probably duplicate
this guy
see then we'd have to scale it up though
I think that's the move
moving
this guy underneath
duplicate that background again
this time
we want
to do this part
and imagine this with full color and
everything yes that that is what
that is what I want
can't wait to get to that point but this
is me just testing
see if all this stuff actually works
and I'm gonna mask out these little
pieces here these assets
foreign
and then technically these guys will be
behind
these guys
there we go
yes
[Music]
it's working
so honestly like
this morning I didn't know what I was
gonna do on the stream I thought I was
gonna be like tracing
the three like the ring in 3D frame by
frame
but
every morning I sit down and I Journal
it's something that I've been doing
since the beginning of this year
um just a few pages every day
like the first thing I do right and
I was just kind of thinking and writing
out to myself like what what am I gonna
do on the stream like or rather it
wasn't what I'm gonna do on the stream
it was more just me
um
thinking out loud or thinking through
writing to myself on like how I'm gonna
do this art and I kind of came up with
this whole process
then and there
and it's working it's really exciting
it's awesome it's awesome it's awesome
for the last tier maybe we'll we'll flip
them around
so I'll just do scale negative 100
that way we get a little different
look going right
[Music]
and yes technically these people would
be smaller okay
I'll give you that and technically the
ones there should be smaller too they
should be getting smaller all the way
towards the back so I should be really
scaling these guys down
um as I'm doing this but let's go like
90 or something I don't know
foreign
[Music]
and once again
let us duplicate the background
foreign
mask and I believe
memory serves
I went with a straight line on this back
one
that's when I figured out how to draw
straight lines
in Photoshop
cool and then we'll take all of that
behind everything there we go
and we get duplicating
lots of layers here lots of layers I
thought about it right I thought about
while I was journaling this morning and
thinking about how I was going to do
this
I'm like well yeah I could do everything
in After Effects but I feel like there
would just be so imagine each one of
these people is a layer
and we already have so many layers with
this full asset I'm like nah
uh-uh I ain't doing that
maybe you can do it with a particle
system but I'm just more comfortable in
uh in Cinema 4D
this is crowd
it's year 2.3
we'll give it that levels adjustments
and look at that
we have a crowd and now
that we're at this point
um
we can update all the way from Photoshop
so I can change this let me just try it
let me try it
um
what would I want to do with this how
would I want to change these um
technically I'm pretty happy with how
this looks
to be honest with you guys I'm pretty
darn happy with it um yes it'll be in
color
eventually
[Music]
also I kind of want to adjust this guy
here this first first tier
just want to scoot them over
ah it's not that big of a deal
but I think yeah I think you guys get
the idea like we could update them and
everything and once you save them out
from Photoshop you just have to
re-render from c4d and since it's the
same it's like referencing the same
asset it's very that's why it's called
like a system right is um it's easily
updatable and maybe there would be a
faster way to update this thing but
I'm actually really happy with with this
so
let's um let's render this out oh come
on now let's render this out
and see if we can't get it up in
c4d looking good I can probably use
these guys up here too
but in terms of testing
let's render this out
and you can actually see what we need to
change based off of that right so
let's go ahead and Export this as a
it's a JPEG sequence
so when I make templates here in After
Effects I'll always start with an
underscore
that way
it's at the top of the list
I have to fish for it
and we'll edit this
jpeg sequence full quality
yes
[Music]
right so bam it's at the top of the list
now jpeg sequence
cool
and let's export this
um
I guess this would be an asset
background
this is background V2
sweet
yeah the underscore trick is a good one
it's a good one
um
you guys are looking for clarification
on the rules for format uh or aspect
ratio 1920x810 that is correct
I don't see I don't see anywhere 1920 by
1080 it's 1920x810 yeah
Franklin what's up Franklin we're making
2D art but we're cheating and we're
using 3D to help us out
um
I'm about to do a little render here and
here we're gonna see it all come
together
use the loop
expression I don't know the loop
expression but I'm gonna try something
crazy right now
um let's let's try it together
let's see if this works
I'm going to log into chat GPT
and see if chat gbt
can give us
an After Effects Loop expression I'm
sure I could Google it
but we'll see
all right
right me and after
effects
Loop expression
uh okay okay
I mean is this it let's see let's copy
it it says make a new composition add a
shape or layer the composition you want
to you want to animate now select the
position property of the layer and you
can apply the following Loop expression
okay let's see if that works
let's just try it on uh
I'll make a new composition
here Ctrl K is comp settings
we'll give it 100 frames and I want this
to Loop
so it says position I'm going to alt
click this little stopwatch down here in
position boom and I'm just gonna paste
what what chat said and see if that
works
that didn't work
um jeez is it a time thing like I feel
like it's not position right
[Music]
what would that be
if I right click time enable timer
mapping
and stretch that out it's going to
animate and then it's going to stop
right you see it animates once boom and
it stops
if I
pick whip time remapping and paste that
it gives me an error
hmm
[Music]
so we need to enable hold on time
remapping
see so you said this keyframe I've never
done this before let's see if a keyframe
assistant
is
toggle hold keyframe
okay that doesn't work
it's the quickest way to do this what do
you guys think
select and choose a loop loop out
uh this final keyframe
assistant
select keyframe where is where is this
Loop out
your time equal previous following I
will hold keyframe interpolation
Control Alt t for timer map loop out
cycle
Loop out
yes guys thank you there you go
so what did chat say
Loop duration Loop duration amplitude oh
wait wait wait wait wait is this
so I copied the whole thing I wonder if
I was just supposed to copy a portion of
this or something
no no no looks like the whole thing
the whole thing
right me
and after effects
expression to Loop
uh
a layer in time I don't know
foreign
okay yeah
but that's good to know that's good to
know guys it's gonna help me out there
for sure
I like that
sweet all right back to back to Cinema
4D
so if I go to my background test
go ahead and close this
back in here bam all right so what I
want to do
is I have this layer set up
right
it's just a plain set to the actual size
of the
background drawing that I made and I've
used a Bend
it's either a modifier or an effector I
think it's a modifier and I'm bending
this around to have it kind of look like
it's 3D right
it matches up with the actual project
file good stuff good stuff so I just
want to update this with an animated
jpeg sequence as opposed to a still
frame so here's what I'll do
let's go ahead and
first of all let me name this this
background V1
and do background V2
sweet
go up in here
amazing all right so I just want to load
an image sequence
[Music]
background V2
that's so confusing
[Music]
let me fix that that's really confusing
uh let's see assets
background V2
underscore V1
not helpful
[Music]
me too all right great
so let's try that again
two we're gonna load this first image
and it's just it's just the image
um let's see
I
how do I do this in octane
how to use an octane God dang it
animation there we go animation
calculate 119 frames frame rate should
technically be 24.
frame 0 to 119 that's 120 frames exactly
amazing I'll set this as
float material because it's a black and
white image
it was color I would just leave it as
normal
now let's give this a shot
Moment of Truth
background V2 pop that on the plane
it looks like it's updated
and it's gonna be really hard to tell
but in theory they should be working so
I don't see anything moving yet
so I'm going to render out
uh I guess I don't need a render I can
just go to the live viewer octane live
viewer
this
do we see the background moving
it's so hard to tell I don't think it's
moving
so here's what I'll do anytime I'm
testing something I'll go into a new
a new project
um
[Music]
Arturo what's up dude
hey man good to see you thanks for
hopping in how's life
been a minute man
let's try this again let's go octane uh
diffuse material
on here
let's drag this out
image texture
let's find something that I know is
animated
um do I have anything
uh
[Music]
animation calculate 24 frames
foreign
do I need to go to editor animate
preview
maybe that's what it is I need to hit
animate preview
look at this look at look look what
we're look what we've become guys
my goodness
[Music]
there we go
I had to hit animate preview I guess
uh let me just be sure if I uncheck it
do we still is it still animated
it is still animated without anime
preview okay so that just means
let's render it and let's see okay
[Music]
and I think it just comes down to like
this test will tell us what we need to
what we need to tweak so maybe the
animation needs to be a bit more
dramatic you need to go further double
you know the height
um on the next one
so
that'll you know this this animation
will will give us our answer let me hop
in with you guys here while this renders
and we can just chat it out do a little
q a
foreign
and then I should bounce so this weekend
this freaking weekend dude
I'm I guess I'm just a fiend because
this weekend
myself my wife and 10 other people are
getting together and we're doing a 48
Hour film challenge
which basically means that tonight
we're gonna be given the genre we're
going to be given a character a prop a
line of dialogue and we're gonna have to
write something shoot something edit
something uh that fits within those
parameters
and that's going to be over this weekend
it's gonna be intense
so I got that tonight I gotta gotta
figure out
what the genre is all that good stuff
um but we got a super fun team together
and shout outs here to sodomonte who put
the logo to get well he didn't put the
logo together
um Gabe
um peregrino put the logo together and
then sodomonte took those assets and
made this awesome transition
um for this challenge so shout outs to
both you guys
yes I'm going to Camp mograph I will be
there
um in Colorado
after this challenge pretty much this
challenge wraps up and I'm headed out to
Camp
um
that's gonna be sweet I'm very excited
for that
[Music]
uh can we
to get work together with other people
for the boss fight challenge like one or
two other people
um no it's one one person per submission
um two or three people cannot
uh submit and then then you gotta like
split prizes that's gonna be yeah it's
confusing uh one person per submission
because it's only fair if you have 10
people working on the same render then
it's like those people can get a lot
more done
than one person
um in theory right so
I know right so the for the film
challenge it's uh I think it's like a
two gig upload limit and you can upload
uh the online it doesn't have to be a
hand drop situation
what else you guys if you have any
questions maybe the app Punisher here
let me take a look
um Hector uh thank you for the kind
words you have a question about the slow
motion you said rule number two since
rule number two is Inc um incorporate a
sense of slow motion your question is
isn't the scene already in slow motion
um slash isn't the camera just animated
in slow motion
um I I wouldn't say that just because
there's a there's like a fast to slow
in the project file that it is slow
motion I think that's getting you
halfway there I think you need to take
that and add some slow-mo elements to
your render
um to justify that camera move so
as long as it feels slow motion that's
okay that that's all it's it's going for
um
so that yeah that that's it I know that
slow motion is going to be
um there's going to be different levels
of slow motion in people's render some
people might go super slow where you can
like see raindrops Frozen in midair and
some people might go slow-mo where it's
just a sliver of slow-mo at One Moment
In the Middle of the render or something
so as long as it feels slow-mo or you're
using slow-mo throughout your five
seconds then you're good
um pineapple and pizza I used to be an
absolutely not the kind of guy but to be
honest with you I'm kind of down
um
for me it's pepperoni jalapeno and
pineapple that that's my favorite pizza
for sure
um what's the limit to adding 2D to your
3D piece I would say there's no limit
really
um we have some people pipoxo here he's
doing full
2D scene but it feels 3D because he's
referencing the 3D the 3D art he's using
um or the 3D project file and he's using
the 3D template
um or to build out a 3D World and he's
going off of that so I would say there's
no limit
all right
hmm
Steve
begins Sensei Steve in the chat
if y'all don't know Steve begin
he's the one who taught me unreal he's
the one who took
hours out of his Friday to humbly teach
me the ways of Unreal Engine
um so I'm
forever grateful
um but it's good to see you Steve we did
a stream together too
um way back way back you guys can see it
if you go back into the Vault here uh we
built out the like radar dish giant
raider dish in the middle of the forest
pretty sweet
Maddie you have an error with your
Houdini scene
I don't know I can't help you with that
one
um maybe sodomonte would know right off
the bat but because yeah sodomonte was
the one who built out the Houdini scene
I don't know man there's errors left and
right
I I don't know if it's a project file
wide error which I doubt I feel like we
would have uh
we would have a lot of people yelling at
us if that was the case but maybe ask
around and chat first to see what you
can find
Sam thank you man I appreciate the kind
words
I really do that's awesome
thanks for for hopping in with me
everybody
[Music]
what's the difference between the medium
and the far templates one is further
than the other you know that's about it
you'd have to open up the project file
and look inside
oh man I forgot about the hacky sack on
stream yeah I gotta do some more of that
probably I mean shoot
not today we'll do it later we'll do it
on the next stream next week we'll do
some hacky sack
but yeah guys we have 530 people
chilling up in here thank you so much
for for sticking with me and I'm excited
to show you this final result
um I'm excited we built out a crowd
system in a couple hours that's really
freaking awesome I'm excited about that
um it's giving me hope for the rest of
my render every step of the way is a
question mark since I've never done this
workflow before and uh
I think we uncovered something here on
stream together so
I'm excited for it
does the boss have to be a living thing
no it does not have to be a living thing
all right y'all it looks like we're
getting close here I'm gonna switch back
over renner's gonna be done pretty darn
soon here
foreign
let's see
[Music]
yeah they're moving back there they're
moving that's great
it's a little hard to tell I think I
need to
scale up these foreground people I think
they need to be a bit larger like double
the size to be honest
and have the background people go to
that that should be the smallest right
and then work up to double that size and
then I think you'd be able to to tell
the difference in the way that they're
animated
um a little bit more
but you can see they're moving
they're cheering back there that's
awesome yes it works
it works yes that is so satisfying
heck yeah
oh that's awesome
so I'm about to figure this out but like
um how I'm gonna do the foreground
that's that's a question definitely for
me is a question how the heck am I gonna
do that
um
because I don't want to be sitting here
tracing
every other frame for this sumo guy the
reason I'm doing it in 2D is because
well one I love drawing and I want to
incorporate that style
I've never done it before but two I am
not good with 3D
um character animation specifically like
character animation kills me
so I'm trying to figure out a unique way
to to do this right
um Tomac thank you for the Super Chat
man that's what's up
absolutely yeah I'm glad I'm glad that
it's helpful for y'all
um yeah so papoxo I feel like at at the
most I'm probably gonna do 12 FPS I was
referencing some scenes from Avatar uh
The Last Airbender
last night and they had the characters
animated on twos which is every other
frame
and then
um there was a slow-mo sequence and they
were animated on threes every three
frames
so when it goes to this moment here
um I'll probably have them animated on
threes
right this slow-mo little area and also
another thing I learned was that
the say like the character
um themselves their arms their hair
their clothes blowing in the wind all
that stuff is animated separately from
the character's position in 2D space
so I think I'm gonna break that up and
this might be a totally obvious thing
um for animators but for me never having
never done it before
I think that's going to be huge is
separating the like X Y movement of the
character on screen
from the actual animation of the
character's face and arms and stuff
um
because in my scene I'm gonna have the
sumo wrestler leap into the air and be
you know
kind of moving up a little bit and then
coming back down maybe they crash down I
don't know yet
but I think what I'll do first is just
animate the character
their limbs and then I'll leave any of
the vertical animation to after effects
or c4d you know
I think that's the idea
um yes 24 FPS is a must 24fps is a must
um
and I think what I'm going to do is my
background is actually going to be
animated uh
let's see the background is going to be
animated uh on 24 frames a second so
it'll be moving every frame
characters will be moving on every two
frames
right so I think that's what we'll do
[Music]
all right let's uh let's watch this
thing in full screen shall we
so here here's what we started with at
the beginning of the Stream
and then here's where we're at
yes dude yes that totally works
totally works I can't wait to do this in
color
just have it be super vibrant
um
the goal again I'll show you guys
color wise
style wise is to do
like this
[Music]
right so just imagine this color
and the vibrancy and everything and the
line art all that
but over this
so that's the goal that is the goal
ah I feel good about it I feel really
good about it
sweet okay yeah if you guys have any
more questions I'm happy to answer
questions for the next five minutes here
and then uh
and then I'm gonna get back to it
you know what now let's let's leave it
on the art I'm happy with that
well Phoenix there is a challenge going
on
it wasn't even announced a week ago it
was last Saturday uh when we did this so
there's still plenty of time the
deadline is the 29th
August 29th I'm pretty sure I'm getting
that right if you go to my YouTube
channel
the the main banner across the top of my
YouTube channel
will actually have the entire schedule
for you guys
27th 7th of the deadline thank you Santa
Monte
29th was the announcement
sweet
um and next week guys I will have
the submission link for you okay so
people can start submitting their art by
next week next time I stream it'll be
live that does not mean that you guys
have to submit it just means there's a
submission link
um what we want to try to avoid is
having people
um submit too early
[Music]
and uh we just want you guys to use as
much time as you have in order to make
your art looking as nice as possible
that's that's really it right
how do I feel about the progress from
the community so far I'm loving it man
seriously so in the Discord server uh
under the what is it uh
what's the what's the channel called let
me get you guys here in a second
feedback yeah there's a feedback Channel
under the boss fight challenge category
um under get started announcements
discussion we got feedback right and
everyone's got their own little Forum
page almost where you can go through and
look at all the art that's coming in go
to gallery view and scroll down and look
at some awesome stuff
um
yeah there's some incredible art so far
um and incredible drawings like oh yes
it looks so good it looks so good and
that's really what I want to feature
um on Monday right so uh this upcoming
Monday
right you guys can join us on Discord
we're going to be doing a voice chat
session with the whole Community
um well it'll be myself and the
moderators up on the stage talking it
out for an hour and bringing you guys up
every five minutes
um to talk about your art to talk about
what you're struggling with talk about
how you're feeling about everything
um and it's a really great way to show
off all the art from the community
before you know leading up to the top
100 live stream that we're doing with
rap grassetti and of course the top 100
Montage with disasterpiece scoring the
music for that so I'm really excited
about this one
um and yeah you know like
I I what I'm trying to do is just
experiment and have fun I'm okay with it
if it turns out that it's like a little
bit further along than this that's cool
I'm having a good time with it
um
so and I hope you guys are as well
see any questions will a version of the
thumbnail or logo be available
um to use in thumbnails and social media
I think we can yeah we can probably post
something up there pin it in the uh
maybe in discussions or something
I know we did it last time for Endless
engines
Ray what's up Clint if you use only c4d
or blender should I learn unreal
how will my workflow my workflow benefit
um it took me like dude it took me like
a year to
to bust out something that I was proud
of outside of unreal and I think now you
can do something a lot faster
um I literally all the unreal tutorials
on my page here on my channel
is
tutorials for me when I first started
it's like things I wish I would have
known right so
it's tough It's not it's definitely but
it's definitely not something that like
you know if you want I don't know here's
the thing if if you want to participate
in this challenge
um and you know c4d and you know blender
really well then go with that
if your goal is to use this challenge to
learn something new like I'm like I'm
here learning a new art style
then maybe you would you'd want to pick
up unreal and mess around with it a
little bit for the challenge I think it
does come down to like a mix of both
where you're playing your strengths but
you're also embracing growth
um and I think visual is the one who put
that so nicely
um in the guidelines
and I I totally agree I think we're
gonna play to your strengths here
um in this case I love drawing
and uh I think technically I kind of
have a grasp on how this works but I'm
also learning something new because I'm
doing a new art style I'm I'm doing new
workflows right so it's a mixture of
both
60fps no 24. uh let's see
[Music]
thank you
can you use a live action element in the
project
um sure yeah you can go for it I know
that someone made a
time lapse submission for moving
meditations it was BoJack Horseman it
was a time lapse one uh probably in the
first third of the video
and they had a like miniature almost
claymation looking scene
and there were hands coming in at you
know rapid Pace just like moving the
different pieces right of the claymation
and those hands were actually just green
screen elements their actual hands that
they comped into the render over top and
it looked it was perfect it looks so
good
um so yeah people have done that in the
past for sure
can we have an object moving
fast
and the rest of the animation is slow
like quicksilver in the kitchen scene
yeah of course of course
[Music]
sweet guys I'm gonna have to call it
soon
[Music]
um I think that's everything here I'm
just reading all you guys the questions
can you change the horizon line I don't
know maybe that's an artistic choice if
you make it work you make it work you
know
lots of questions here
generally guys
um if it if it fits into the montages if
you don't don't touch the camera don't
mess with the timing of it
um keep the boss the size of the boss
keep the hero the size of the hero that
you see here on on my screen
um you know have fun with it I think
outside the box
you definitely can bend some of the
rules but just know that it is a
competition and if you bend the rules
too far it may not work out and you may
not get into the all renders or the top
100 but just know these rules are in
place so that all of your guys's art
fits into the overall Montage right
foreign
have to be bigger than the hero yes
absolutely like this is the scale you
guys want to go for is this scaling here
we have big medium and far
project files obviously we're looking at
the close-up this is the close-up one
you can clearly see that they're
pretty close to each other maybe 10 feet
apart whereas like this
that thing is way out there right that
thing's a mile two miles tall that's why
we have the the large project file or
the far sorry the far project file
all right guys
I think that's it
thank you for
sticking uh sticking around I'll be here
next Friday hopefully further along the
scene uh I'll see you on Monday on the
Discord server for our little uh Town
Hall
chat and um
yeah other than that good luck to you
guys next week we got a submission link
for you
uh have fun with it seriously guys have
fun it's a good time keep learning keep
growing
I'll see you all on Monday on the
Discord Friday same time
for the live stream next week all right
guys peace out have a good one it was
nice hanging with you guys it was a good
stream I felt good about that catch
y'all later
[Music]